dutch farmers are angry they say plans
by the government to reduce nitrogen
emissions will harm their livelihood the
netherlands is the second largest
agricultural exporter so what is this
going to mean for global food supplies
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm rob
matheson farmers in the netherlands are
blocking roads setting fire to haystacks
and even driving tractors through the
streets of the hague it's all in protest
against laws that regulate emissions
produced by livestock but are likely to
have a major impact on the farming
community and the larger economy the
netherlands has failed to meet its
emissions reduction targets so permits
for new homes and roads have not been
granted since 2019 to prevent further
pollution and the government's
introducing tough new rules it's 100
billion dollar food export industry one
of the biggest in the world could be
badly affected and this is happening
when the war in ukraine is already
putting global food supplies at risk now
we're going to bring in our guests in a
moment first this report from steph
vassen in nekherek in the netherlands
farmers have said they want to paralyze
the entire country they have announced
that they want to block access to the
main airport skip hall other airports
the port and rotterdam the situation has
been escalating between farmers
organizations the farmers themselves and
also the government on the other side in
the last couple of weeks they have been
farmers detained at certain actions
police was involved there has been
aggression also towards the minister and
now here we are at the food distribution
center one of the 25 that are being
blocked today by farmers and let's have
a look around we see
the trucks here they were ready to go to
supermarkets full of food meat dairy
products you can hear the cooling
machine still running but they can't go
anywhere because look at the other side
there are tractors there are trucks
there are farmers sitting here they say
no
farmers no food so they say we want to
let the people in the netherlands know
that
the farms can't be closed because
they're very essential for food
production around the country
the government has announced that the
farms have to cut more than 50 percent
of the nitrogen emissions in some areas
even up to 90 percent there has been
research showing that the effects of
nitrogen pollution on the ecosystems in
the netherlands is pretty dramatic and
the farmers also say that these figures
are not correct they say we want a
better solution the government has
announced that they want a mediator to
be involved but the farms farmers have
said this mediator is not acceptable to
us they're sitting here
they're waiting here for maybe two up to
two days
some of them we spoken to them before
have already sold their farms because
they were not capable financially to run
their business
you can see here slogans uh if there is
no farmers
there won't be food in the supermarkets
that's what they say some have even
brought
some hay they're fitting here on it they
brought their wooden shoes
it's really a protest
they say they had no choice
we are fed up and if you push us to the
limit this is what we're gonna do but
the question of course remains today how
the dutch public will respond to this
when there's no food or there's empty
shelves in supermarkets today so what's
the plan that's caused so much anger
well dutch farmers have been told to cut
nitrogen emissions to between 12 to 70
percent depending on how close they are
to conservation areas those areas are
part of what the european union is
calling natura 2000 it's the largest
coordinated network of protected areas
in the world farmers whose land is
inside natural reserves will have to cut
by ninety percent and those who can't do
that will have one of three options
switch to crop farming relocate or quit
the trade
[Music]
okay let's bring in our guests they're
all joining us from the netherlands in
zevalde we have jerome van maanen he's a
dairy farmer and a protest organizer in
amsterdam natasha oloman is a food and
agriculture expert at the worldwide fund
for nature netherlands and
theo manderslaute is a mediator between
producers and buyers at agracon he's
also a member of agrati is one of the
largest farmers action groups in the
netherlands a very warm welcome to you
all thank you very much indeed for being
with us natasha i want to start with you
this is about nitrogen and ammonia at
its heart
what why are they thought to be so bad
well ammonia and nitrogen specifically
has a huge impact on biodiversity
especially in nature areas
and unfortunately the dutch agricultural
sector is one of the major contributions
to nitrogen emissions affecting
biodiversity in the netherlands we still
have we are facing a biodiversity crisis
and this is because of decades of
government looking away
and finally the government has made a
decision to do something about it
and this is causing a major disruption
because farmers weren't aware that they
needed to change but basically this is
not a surprise it has been going on for
decades and now there's finally an
opportunity to make this change
and to have the budget
to be um to enable farmers to actually
transition to a more sustainable nature
friendly way of producing food
jerome you're shaking your head there is
this about nitrogen and pollution or is
there something else going on here
no well we have we have a few different
problems but
the main cause of this hole is
because some left-wing parties in the
dutch government want to have a reduced
reduction of the dutch national herd
at least by 30 percent well they wanted
to have 50 percent but that's the main
cause of all and when we look into the
nature the point like natasha ulemans
was telling you about
reports
all of them say over the last few years
85 of that nature is in perfect
condition
of the 15 percent of the nature which is
not in good condition
there are about 1500 ways to improve the
nature and
about 50
of these
1500 ways
is not even
done yet in the netherlands
and nitrogen pollution is only one of
them so that's what the dutch farmers
are saying when some bit of nature the
15
needs to be improved that's okay
but then we use all the different ways
you can do to improve nature and
nitrogen pollution is only one of them
so in this case
and what we also say as agriculture
sector
over the last 30 years we already
reduced almost 70 percent as agriculture
sector
so uh on this point uh no none other
sector did
a reduction like agriculture did over
the last 30 years
natasha i know you want to come in but i
do want to bring in theo mandaslone here
the dutch government as um natasha was
explaining has
brought together some sort of attempt at
a solution and yet it seems to be
constantly rejected by the farmers why
are none of these solutions acceptable
uh the dutch government doesn't uh
is is only working in one way
we as we as a farmers organization the
netherlands or offered the dutch
government
i think almost thousands of uh
suggestions to do something but uh to do
something to reduce uh
nitrogen and this kind of uh into uh to
uh to help the nature but uh
it is not about the nitrogen it's about
re rearranging the public space in the
netherlands and uh this is the only
reason why the government is not
speaking with farmers but uh but over
farmers and not
uh not as uh not as taking the handshake
what the farmers wants to give to the
government because we have forbid
because we have the farmers
give a lot of a lot of suggestions about
uh uh lowering nitrogen uh
trying to uh to make the nature better
to uh to help the environment to do uh
something with uh with uh some with with
uh with the water qualities and
everything more and the the dutch
government just is telling something
about
the eureka uh about uh
critical goals and uh not about uh and
nothing about uh innovation and um
and uh
possibility solutions
so this is this is this is the reason
why we we that why why we are in this
way are protesting because
uh because the government is not
listening in any way to the farmers they
just taking their own way and going
straight forward to uh to reach their
goals instead of looking at nature
because the farmers
need nature tribute to produced endless
highest level in the world and what at
the moment is happening is that the
government just telling something about
about nitrogen and
[Music]
and
a lot of a lot of higher levels but the
topic that better the if this were
really a problem then they would also
suggest to speak about
our airports about uh freight for
about the barges about freight about
traffic and this kind of thing but none
of them are involved in some with some
measures only the landscape and the
farmers will be threatened by our
government so this is not okay
let me bring you in there because both
geron and theo are saying that this is
the nitrogen and the impact of nitrogen
and ammonia is forms a small part of of
the situation that in fact this is about
a wider issue that the government is
actually wanting to change the land use
within the country what's your response
how do you react to that
my response is as follows
there's no doubt that biodiversity is
affected by nitrogen in the netherlands
there are numerous reports that are
indicating that but something needs to
change and not from an ecological
perspective but also from a legal
perspective and that's why the highest
court in the netherlands rules that
nitrogen depositions in the netherlands
and emissions should reduce by 50
in 2030. so uh but apart from that i
agree with the other speakers that there
is more happening in the netherlands
because we also have a water quality we
have an air
quality problem the water quality in the
netherlands is far below what is needed
to comply with the um water framework
directive in europe so our drinking
water our our groundwater is at the
moment so polluted and agriculture is
also one of the polluters of that so
apart from nitrogen affecting
biodiversity we are also talking about
air pollution and water pollution and
this is also the reason i think why we
need to have a transition of agriculture
that is sticking all those boxes of
things that need to change and this
major transformation of agriculture even
though it will affect farmers it can
also be seen as an opportunity to really
transition a broken food system into a
system that is good for nature but also
provides a future for farmers a new
future because the system that we are in
right now is a system that is broken and
is not working for farmers every day
five farmers in the netherlands stop
their business because there's no future
so the current system is not working for
farmers it's not working for
biodiversity it's not working for our
health
because
the air quality in the netherlands is
really below a level
that is healthy
so i do agree with them that not only
agriculture needs to change but that we
also have to look at
at
traffic at industries and so on but the
fact is and that's
the thing with the nitrogen case is that
um agriculture at the moment and
especially dairy farming
is contributing the most with 60 of the
national emissions is being caused by
the mainly the dairy sector so that's
the start of the change but i totally
agree that we have to look much broader
and that we have to look at a situation
in which the current system in the
netherlands both for food producing and
the way we use our land
needs to be rearranged and it means
especially for farmers that a transition
is needed but that's why the government
also puts 35 billion euros
and in the budget
over the next decades to help with that
transition and to support that
transition and i would really really
value if farmers would come up with an
offer in how they can contribute and
what the price
and the costs are that society also has
to pay because i do think that this
problem is not being caused by farmers
because they are also a victim of the
current system but that the farmers are
the solution and that they can help in
bringing the netherlands to a future
where it's green not only for nature but
also for us people
i'm going to stop you there because i
want to bring in jerome forgive me for
interrupting you but i want to bring in
jerome because he clearly is has got
very strong feelings about this jordan
explain something to me because
from what i've heard so far the
government seems to have an end goal of
improving the environment within the
netherlands so do the farmers from what
theo was saying
it's intrinsic to the farmers it's
important to the farmers that nature
should be sustained that their
livelihood should be sustained where is
where is this breaking down where is the
problem with this that when you're both
working towards the same end goal if you
like you can't find some sort of common
ground to be able to move forward
but i wanted to respond on what uh mr
natasha said that just right now
um it's not true it's and it's very
hypocrite also whatever problem you look
at if it's nitrogen pollution if it's
maintained
if it's co2 or whatever the use of
antibiotics
dutch agriculture is champion of the
world
right now when we focus on
nitrogen pollution
we can the law which is now a plan from
our minister
uh it will cause that probably about 40
of the dutch farmers uh have to stop
their business and production
will have to get away outside of holland
you know every country in the world is
on a lower standard for nitrogen
pollution for co2 or whatever problem so
when we get rid of dutch farmers other
farmers in the world need to
take care of the same production we need
more land use there's more use of water
all the problems natasha is saying you
know you can say something about dutch
water quality and it always can be
improved we have innovations for that
but when you put
food production to other countries in
the world standards were lower so then
in 10 years time the dutch citizens are
eating food which is produced on a lower
standard then it's produced right now
you know when we want to solve a problem
we have not only holland in the world
but we need to see climate and nitrogen
as a worldwide problem and then we can
improve the world
by getting to dutch standards not only
to get rid of farmers in holland because
it's only moving the problem away out of
sight and and nothing is solved so it's
it's ridiculous and also hypocrite theo
let me ask you this because from what i
if i understand natasha correctly the
government has put money in place in
order to be able to help farmers
transition from livestock when this is
predominantly livestock farming that
we're talking about
to move from livestock farming into crop
farming it's providing money for farmers
who feel that they're not able to meet
the standards so that the farms will be
bought out um
it seems to me as though the government
is at least putting some money towards
us let me ask you this
what is preventing livestock farmers
from making the transition from animal
to crop farming
um the
the the the biggest the biggest issue is
that the government is was is as uh
unreachable goals in their um in their
for themselves they just and they only
speaking over farmers not with farmers
they not uh interested in any innovation
or in any solution
what they reached also from the
agricultural sector we are we are
working as as agricultural sector
already for decades on innovation and on
solutions for to uh to reduce our
emissions
and um what's happening what's up what
what's happening now is that our
government in the past
pointed or 162 areas of
wish nature
this nature they want to have some some
habitats in it which which they want to
have
to come or they want to have to protect
some some some little insects or
something so that's really nice and we
like this also as farmers but the
biggest issue is that um with that with
if they using the nitrogen not nitrogen
goals if we
every just empty the whole netherlands
all farmers all citizens we still have a
huge problem because we have the
nitrogen and the
the
water quality which is coming from uh
the eastern part of europe and what's
floating into your into the netherlands
so we can do what you want and we can
try to to to do the best what we have
but it is not reachable it's not
possible furthermore it sounds a really
nice 35 million euro euros for the a
million euros for the for the iukel
sector in the netherlands for the
farmers but
this is not the truth
first of all they don't have the money
for it and uh
the second is that they
uh
second is they have
uh two
uh
they have to uh
try to improve something and uh try to
help the farmers with uh some change
with some changes but if you look at
what what was happening in a few weeks
ago in our of one one week ago in our
government we had a dutch farmer which
getting money from the government for
his nature goals and the dutch
government was telling i was telling him
okay it was very nice that you changed
your farm to nature living and but this
year we will end your
payments for your for all your efforts
and so this guy was
totally totally lost and he doesn't know
what to do because his company his
company's farm he has to quit with us
from because the government is quitting
to pay the money and
the biggest issue is that
our government is telling that they want
to pay for everything and they want to
do a lot of things and they want to
they want to change and they won't have
change but the farmers want also to
change but our government is not
trustable and this is the biggest issue
natasha do you think that given the the
food crisis that the world is facing at
the moment because of the the the war in
ukraine and the restrictions on grain
and so forth do you think that whilst
zero emissions may well be a great um
objective for governments around the
world this is not the right time for any
government to be trying to bring in this
kind of thing
it is the right time to make a change
and i i'm i'm honestly a bit surprised
by the arguments that the two others
theomanders and vanman are are telling
us because they i obviously feel that
they are still in the illusion that the
netherlands is feeding the world the
netherlands is not feeding the world
because a lot of grains also from the
ukrainian past but also from
brazil soy is coming to the netherlands
to feed animals
these are
feedstock that can easily be used
directly by humans to eat so
producing meat and dairy in the
netherlands in a very intensive way
which has been causing a lot of damage
to nature a lot of damage to water
quality and to our air quality and our
health
is not the solution for feeding the
world the netherlands is being proud
that we are the best producers but the
best producers in the netherlands it
maybe refers to the amount of production
that we are doing per hectare or per
animal but it has caused enormous
societal and environmental problems so
if you look at if you take that into
account in the societal
cost that it's taking apart from all the
subsidies that farmers need in order to
make a living in the netherlands most
farmers are dependent for half their
income on european subsidies to to
survive so the dutch system is broken
and this is not only me as a nature
conservationist is saying this this is
what our government is saying this is
what many scientists are saying so there
is a change needed especially now with
the operating crisis because we need to
to feed the world
in such a way that we use land
efficiently and to me it's not a
legitimation that you feed animals
the same crops and the same pulses that
can be fed directly to humans
so i do think especially in this
situation that we both need a rethinking
of the way we are producing and the way
we are consuming and how to support that
and nature both in the netherlands and
worldwide and biodiversity is not a nice
to have for nature and for wild animals
it's a need to have for us as humans
because we are dependent on nature if
there are no pollinators anymore then we
don't have crops to eat
if we don't have a healthy soils then we
cannot produce food in the future
if we don't have healthy water streams
then we cannot have drinking water so i
do think that the netherlands especially
because we have the most intensive
farming system in the world we we are
basically a wake-up call for the rest of
the world to change jerome i want to
bring in i want to bring you in there
because on the back of what natasha is
saying given the fact that we are in
this worldwide food crisis that is
facing and given the role that the
netherlands has been playing as one of
the major exporters of of food to the
world
this would sound like it would be a good
opportunity for the netherlands to make
the most of that and to be able to break
in
i really want to break in into the
framework just very quickly natasha
please
yeah we are not the major exporter in
the world we are importing large
quantities we are exporting large
quantities the amount of that natasha
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop you there i
take your point i want to go very
briefly uh to to jerome we only have
about a minute left jerome given the
fact coming back to my original point
given the situation in the world this
would be an opportunity for the
netherlands to play a role in feeding
the rest of the world
would it not be
to everybody's advantage to the farmers
for the farmers to find a solution to
this problem and quickly and get back to
what they do which is producing food
just very briefly that's right
yes well dutch agriculture can teach the
world a lot of good things and i think
we but we before that we we need to have
an agriculture in holland which is big
enough you know when there's only 10
farms left knowledge will be gone and we
can't teach the world how to do it
we have major solutions for all problems
in the world that's why
we are a world champion on every part of
whatever problem you have
dutch agriculture is needed for that so
i think we need to have strong
national agriculture sector jerome we're
going to leave it there but thank you
very much indeed to all three of you i
want to thank all our guests um jerome
van maanen natasha oilerman and theo
mandis clearly there's a lot of debate
to be had here thank you too for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me rob matheson and the
entire team here in doha bye for now